[Applaudissements]
de remettre le César d'honneur à David
Fincher merci d'accueillir Virginie
Efira
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mon cher David
à cause de vous j'ai perdu mes dernières
illusions sur une conjugalité heureuse
épanouie mais multiples visionnages de
gone girls n'ont pas été sans
conséquence
à cause de vous encore je suis incapable
d'ouvrir une boîte en carton toute seule
je fais croire que mon refus de me faire
livrer par Amazon et politique mais il
n'en est rien évidemment c'est un trauma
consécutif à Seven bon je passe sur
quantité d'autres névroses liés à votre
oeuvre de aucun psy n'arrivera jamais à
bout
et cependant David wow comme je vous
aime et comme je vous remercie et je
sais que c'était l'Andam d'amour est
partagé par toute cette salle enfin les
gens qui nous regardent par le public
français
nous sommes tous de grands malades
amoureux de votre oeuvre et oui comment
ne pas être fou la metteur en scène qui
sait si bien joué avec nos nerfs et
composer des images qui ne s'effaceront
jamais comment ne pas être aimanté par
votre façon de filmer la pluie la
mélancolie la noirceur de scruter la
noirceur la noirceur ou plutôt la
pénombre cette zone grise ou on
distingue sans tout ivoire et où
l'imagination comble le reste
dans un paysage culturel qui aime
fabriquer des héros vous David vous nous
embarquez aux côtés de gens décalés
marginaux ambigu parfois pas aimable du
tout mais ce sont justement ces fêlures
ces imperfections qui les rendent si
humains et qui nous tendent d'un miroir
certes peuplateur mais lucides profond
et d'une incroyable drôle réussie vos
films contiennent tout
l'amour la haine le tragique et le
comique le désir à la répulsion la
question du mal sous toutes ses formes
tout ce mélange se retourne la vérité le
mensonge en premier lieu votre cinéma
brise les codes aide à regarder ses
propres démons et aboli les frontières
quoi de plus nécessaire quoi de plus
beau pour tout ça merci infiniment David
Fincher
et une dernière chose avant de laisser
ce César d'honneur si méritait entre vos
mains il y a quelqu'un qui a tenu à être
présent j'ai mis assez peu d'oppositions
je dois dire un invité spécial qui a
quelques liens avec notre pays mais
surtout avec vos films il se revendique
comme votre partenaire prime Brad Pitt
[Applaudissements]
y
en sortant d'un film de David Fincher
les enfants
bonsoir Je m'appelle Brad Pitt et je
suis à rescapé
si on pouvait tourner ça s'il vous plaît
avant qu'on perd tous le goût de la vie
ok maintenant on a la version flou si on
la refaisait nette
si tu panais sur la droite et que tu
revois ça encore dans le champ tu vois
ma permission pour tenter la vie
et une de mes préférées je voudrais bien
que vous vous amusiez tous mais c'est à
ça que ça sert les weekends
personne n'a dit que c'était facile de
faire un film de Fincher tout le monde
vous dira que ça en vaut la peine
certains disent qu'il est
perfectionniste c'est vrai c'est très
vrai selon la rumeur il a déjà fait 90
prises pour un seul plan c'est
entièrement faux inexact pas vrai du
tout c'était 92
on raconte qu'un cadre de studio était
venu le voir après une projection pour
dire Davy je ne suis pas complètement à
l'aise avec ce montage la seule réaction
de David a été je compatis profondément
c'est vrai c'est vrai
soi-disant pendant qu'il filmait la
naissance de sa fille il aurait demandé
au gynécologue si on pouvait la refaire
ce n'est pas du tout prouvé je ne peux
pas me prononcer
si vous ne l'aviez pas déjà compris
j'adore cet homme de tout mon cœur et je
suis ravi d'appui d'avoir pu lui tendre
cette embuscade ce soir et faire partie
cet hommage à l'un de nos plus grands
compteurs et bravo même d'être arrivé
jusqu'ici car il s'agit d'un homme qui
habite soigneusement le feu des
projecteurs pour des villes c'est quand
il nourrit une idée et qu'il est le plus
content l'innovation la psychologie de
la chose ce qu'il pourra déterrer quand
il commence à tourner il vous dira que
c'est le moment où il commence à ne pas
être à la hauteur de ses aspirations
et c'est là que l'agonie démarre
d'autres réalisateurs essaient souvent
de l’émuler mais ils échouent
invariablement car ils pensent que ce
n'est qu'une question d'imagerie mais si
ce n'était qu'une question d'image nous
ne reviendrions pas encore et encore à
son œuvre sans parler de lui rendre
hommage ce soir pour lui tout est
important tout le temps commencer par
l'histoire et le personnage est 1000
autres petites choses qui doivent aller
correctement pour qu'un seul plan se
retrouve dans son film s'il y a un seul
degré d'écart cela pourrait être la même
chose que 180 degrés d'écart il n'y a
pas de presse il n'y a pas à peu près il
n'y a pas de c'est pas si loin l'idée
qu'il se fait du professionnelalisme
c'est celle que se font la plupart des
gens de l'obsession mais en travaillant
avec lui vous aurez sans aucun doute un
avant-goût de l'excellence et comme il
vous le dirait si on jongle pas avec des
tronçonneuses alors on ne se rend pas
service
ces films parlent d'elle-même donc voici
quelques anecdotes sur Fincher avec sa
première série House of Cards
qui ont décidé de sortir la saison d'un
seul coup ce qui a changé la façon dont
nous regardons nos séries à savoir le
pin's le bouton sauter l'intro adopté
par tous les services de streaming
Fincher aussi et puis la voiture
rôtisserie comme on l'appelle où on peut
voir les acteurs faire des tonneaux dans
presque tous les films oui c'est Fincher
aussi le Hollywood que je côtoie
effrayant du qualificatif de génie mais
il se méprend souvent sur les véritables
génies nous qui avons eu la grande
chance de pouvoir suivre dans son
sillage nous vous dirons qu'il est
chaleureux que c'est une crème
qu'il s'exprime extrêmement bien et que
son honnêteté est rigoureuse et qu'il
prend toujours la peine de vous exposer
sa vision nous essaierons de vous
décrire les perles de sagesse qui sort
de sa bouche de sa bouche sans jamais y
parvenir et qu'il est le plus dur avec
lui-même et même si c'est le plus
intelligent de la pièce il donne dans
l'autodérision et c'est le le
plus drôle que j'ai jamais rencontré il
est fidèle jusqu'à la mort et à notre
tour nous nous traiterions volontiers
sur du vert pilés pour lui redemandant
une prise voici simplement petite chose
que je pourrais dire sur cet homme qui
signifie tellement pour nous ma vie a
changé pour toujours en ce jour de 94 où
j'ai pris un café avec David Fincher je
ne sais pas si ce que nous faisons à son
importance en fin de compte mais je sais
que ce qu'il y a à son importance ce
sont les gens auxquels nous nous
raccrochons et la marque indélébile
qu'il laisse sur notre être mère je
lisais un passage l'autre jour un
personnage demande qu'est-ce qui est le
plus important le voyage ou la
destination
et l'autre lui répond c'est la compagnie
je ne sais pas quoi ajouter à cela
[Applaudissements]